problem in the world but yeah it must be  annoying that the game is still  going on and all of a sudden you have to  start thinking if this knight will do  something  ding took  back to ding  took on c5  here we are  duda shaking his head yeah he's not  happy that this game is still  raging on  but you can't blame yourself you have to  focus what is now and try to get the  best and he's frustrated about what was  missed by him  and this is not good  yeah  but  everyone knows you shouldn't it's very  hard not to though like  if you missed all these moments  do you think there's a strategy like  you say okay i miss this  i'm allowed to be upset now for two  minutes but then  i have to focus again how how do you  cope with with it and there it is you  have to i think it's not a question  it's just you have to force yourself  to  and maybe  to be honest maybe meditation can help  this kind of uh mindset also  but i think it's you cannot  simply